good part c
they introduce a road
jerks okay but that's all right with the
equation of path it's very easy to work
with okay so i'm going to make this a
bit bigger because not enough
room to show you what's going on
okay there's my road okay so obviously
once it hits that it's not going to um
actually go through there so this part
of the graph no longer matters okay
the road is inclined at from the
horizontal at tan inverse
of a fifth
that's a funny angle the reason they
pick that is just to make your numbers a
little easier okay
show that the ball is about nine meters
above the road when it reaches its
greatest height required to prove
nine meters above row
about sorry
there you go okay now how do i work this
out what does height represent in this
equation okay well in the first place
you could just get height from this okay
you just get height from that because
that's what y is about okay but now that
i have a road in the picture
the height is actually something like
this
you know it's it's this distance right
or or this distance or this distance
okay and the important thing you want to
get is that it's very easy to work out
that distance if you know how high this
is and how high this is really easy okay
i've got the equation of path right
what's the equation of this thing what
should we call it i guess you'd call it
equation of road
equation of road
how do i work it out i just want its
gradient don't i how do you find the
gradient of a straight line
it's tan theta isn't it right 10 and in
this case theta is this right
tan of 10 inverse of a fifth so your
gradient is just a fifth
so therefore here's the equation of
road right now therefore if i want to
know this distance right i just have to
take away
how high the ball is from
how high the road is that's all okay so
running out of space i am going to leave
the equation of path there that's all i
need
okay
so i've got this distance
this is the height above the rope okay i
want the greatest one it's going to be
this
whoops
minus this
there you go that's the height at any
given time okay now here's an important
thing for you to notice okay because
i've adjusted this
um two things if i were to graph this
which i'm not going to but if i were to
graph it what kind of shape would it be
it's still a parabola it's still a
problem but importantly it is not the
same parabola as this i mean obviously
it's not the same but if it's not the
same that means it doesn't have the same
greatest height it doesn't have the same
stationary point anymore okay so if all
you did was say okay slap in this okay
and then work out hi how the how high
the road is at that corresponding x
value and you will not get the highest
point because you've got the stationary
point for this guy not the station point
for this guy okay so in order to get
this a little meter here's what i'll do
all i want is is an axis of symmetry
right that's minus b on 2a so all i need
to be able to do is rearrange this so
that b
and a are clear right well
that there
that's a
right
and b is somewhere in here now i think
you'll get this
when you simplify out let me just double
check i think that's what i got yeah
okay good so now if i want my axis of
symmetry
i say it's minus b
on
uh 2a which is which is minus 5 on
72
and you just crunch that out okay
so you get an x value for this this is
an x value where this is okay i think
the fraction is something awkward like
408 on 25
okay that's okay your calculator handles
all of that what am i going to do with
this x value
i should sub it in but where should i
sub it in i have like a hundred
equations that i could choose from which
one
just one up the top isn't it
this will give me the actual distance
it's the it's um nine meters above the
road is what i'm looking for above the
road okay so you take this and you sub
into
the equation
of
road that's a very official
acronym by the way eoi always stands for
equation of road
it doesn't you're not laughing you're
obviously too sad okay so
i'm going to say y equals i'll slap that
in and then i think you get
this
exactly in fact
um i don't think there are any decimal
places because it's a nice number there
okay which of course is approximately
nine meters
okay
are there any questions so far any steps
that have been confusing
all right last bit
we want to show that the time of flight
okay now it does go back to time so i'm
going to have to go back to them in a
second so the time of flight is 2.72
seconds that's an awkward number
and find correct to the nearest tenth of
a meter how far the ball has been thrown
off the road
that's that distance how far the ball is
going thrown up the road
there it is right there
whatever that is okay so
when does the ball
finally hit the road what can we do in
this situation what would be an easy way
of doing this to solve it
hmm
you've got a couple alternatives don't
you number one you could say i just want
to know when the equation of road
intersects with the equation of path
that'll do it won't it okay
and you get that value out
however
being that the previous part of the
question i just worked out this distance
right all i want this distance to be
is zero i want the ball and the road to
be at the same spot okay
so you've got um this solution here
already for an x value can you see that
you see it so if that's remember this is
the axis of symmetry right so this is
halfway
so how much further will i have to go to
get to the ground
i just have to go this distance again
right so i would say this is part c part
what am i doing part two
okay
my x value that corresponds to hitting
the road is just double the axis of
symmetry it's this
that is the place horizontally where i
hit the road okay
that
that value there okay
now very very briefly i just have to go
back to a time equation what's our time
equation i believe it's x equals 12t
isn't it we proved that in part a okay
so all you do is you say well 12t must
equal that
so you divide by 12.
uh
252 300
300
is that right
whatever that is i think that's right
where's my calculator
2.72 hooray there you go
okay can you see
i know i'm doing a lot of talking but
see how little working and how simple
the equations are if the question fits
equation apart
look at this it's just it's so
pedestrian right
okay last part what do i want to work
out
how far up the road it's gone
okay
i already know this value
it's here
okay
816 on 25. you should all be able to
tell me without reaching to your
calculators how high i am
come on look at it what's the equation
of the road
it's x15 is it x x
8 16 on 5. so that should be 125 right
so there you go that's a vertical
distance you've got a horizontal
distance you pull out pythagoras and
that will give you the distance up the
road okay which i think
if i do it right it'll be
33.26 something 286
blah blah blah they went to a tenth of a
meter don't they
okay
can you imagine how complicated that
would be if you thought about these all
in terms of actual time what a mess okay
imagine imagine taking this time back
into your original um
x and y equations and then oh my head
okay
um so there you go that's the way i
approach it